- I can't even believe this,
I didn't open with this
but now you're a mama.
- I am.
- Since the last time
I saw you.
- Yes.
- That's exciting.
- It's the best thing ever.
- That is so...
Look, look, look, look, look.
Baby hands.
- That's her hand.
That's her hand.
- Oh my God.
- That's so ex-
- Yeah. Her name's Emma.
We're in love, it's amazing
and wonderful.
- I love that for you.
It is a special time. I like skin-on-skin
when they're so little, all in the smell.
- And she just started
giggling and laughing
and I can make her laugh,
which as a comedian,
it's the most exciting thing.
- You win.
- But I try really hard
and sometimes she's like
you're not committed enough.
- Yeah.
You're trying too hard.
- Yeah, you're trying
way too hard, honey but
then if I just don't try
and she laughs, it's the best feeling.
- Wait, did you ever give her
any advice with parenting?
I mean since you're a stellar dad and all.
- He is a stellar dad.
- No.
I try to show up to work looking rested
and I continue to tell
her that it's the best.
- It is though and he's a very good dad
and I texted him, he
texted me a couple days
after she was born and
was like, "How's it going?
How is she?" and I was
like, "It's amazing.
I want a hundred kids."
and he just was like,
"No, you don't." and then three months in,
I'm like, "Yeah, yeah, I'm good."
I get it.
- Yeah then you start
to get outnumbered.
- Yeah. Oh, see
- Yeah.
I don't know how that...
'Cause one I'm still like-
- 'Cause I'm a single parent
now so I'm outnumbered
at night and I'm like,
- That's very hard.
- "This is different.'
- Yes, yes.
- This is, yeah.
Yeah.
- I can't imagine that-
- You have to go warrior,
you have to find your inner
warrior to survive.
- If anyone can do it.
- Yeah, I can. Stronger.
- Yeah.
- There we go.
- Sing it, sing it.
I did it. I did it so no one else could.